The effective mass of the rear is obviously way smaller than the mass of the quarter of that car.
Due to its low mass, it is much easier to accelerate than decelerate the wheel
than to accelerate or decelerate the car which has a larger mass.
So when we want to study equilibria of the wheel slip that its values which stays constant,
we can start by thinking about the velocity of the car is a slow variable
and the velocity of the rim of the wheel is a fast variable.
We have cheated a little and say, okay, let's assume that the velocity of the car is almost constant
but assuming that the velocity of the car is almost constant, this idea about the fast changing W
and the slowly changing V helps us to think about the equilibria of the wheel slip.
If that wheel slip reaches an equilibrium, its temporal, its rate of change becomes zero.
It does not change anymore. This is the meaning of equilibrium.
If s doesn't change and V is almost constant,
we learned that W must not change, but we have an equation for the rate of change of W.
It's the friction force divided by the effective mass of W minus the braking deceleration of the wheel.
These two expressions have to be equal.
We find approximately this equation for the equilibria of the wheel slip.
When the wheel slip does not change with time, the friction force
divided by the effective mass of the wheel has to be almost equal
to the deceleration of the wheel by the brake.
Given this equation, the task is now to determine the number of equilibria,
the number of stable equilibria, and the number of unstable equilibra.
For that, assume that the car is braking slightly below the optimum value
and ignore the case that s, the wheels that equals one, which means perfect locking.